So we've entered the Catacombs, and this is pretty insane.
The bones of thousands and thousands of Parisians are piled one on top of another.
And they were brought here because the plague was,...
...disease was like running rampant at the time from the cemeteries,...
...seeping into the water system and everything.
So, this is why they're in the Catacombs.
Pretty intricate work, how all the bones are stacked on top of each other...
...with the skulls on top.
All the bones here in the Catacombs are stacked in sections,...
...and in front of each one is the sign which tells you where the bones came from,...
...which cemetery, as well as what date they were all stacked here.